foreign
for everybody's favorite lightning round
let's do this Kelly
when your producer was a hair metal fan
in the 80s
hi pot have you met the kettle there's
the music all right let's do this all
right first question so we say this
lightning round is about kids and
parenting and I don't know what's coming
nope
you know this I always feel like we're
gonna get canceled let's do this first
question how do we decide if and when
our pre-teen is ready for their own
phone
um the answer is no
ta-da
that's my that's my answer man
I no no pre-teen should have a phone
it's in my opinion I agree with you on
pre-teen yes no pre-teen should have a
phone period
um if a teenager needs a phone
um
it would have to be something that is so
highly restricted there's some special
phones out there and I don't know enough
about the individual companies but it
would have to be something that my kids
cannot have unfettered access to Ai and
the internet and all these insane
opinions about all this insane stuff
everything from sexuality to religion to
Whatever We complain like Psychopaths
about schools what are they teaching in
them schools and then we give our kids
freaking phones are you kidding me
what's the matter with you I would much
rather have a teacher tell my child
something that I disagree with and then
my kid come home and talked to me about
it then have the internet
millions of unfiltered opinions no we
got some blockers on our phones no you
don't your kids are smarter than you
that's my thought on phones ta-da all
right then back to being canceled all
right second question my job causes me
to work long hours how can I make up for
the lost time and connect with my kids
when I am home that's a great question
so one
I hope that there's some cyclical
seasonality to this that this isn't all
of the time 24 7 365. so uh my
brother-in-law works on the railroad so
that means he's gone at strange hours
that also means when he's home he gets
up a little bit early and he takes his
kids to school he drives him to school
he picks him up from school he goes to
performances when he's home so
um same with me when I'm on the road I'm
on the road I'm on the road uh when I'm
writing books and I have to hold up in a
hotel for a week and get something done
like I miss my I miss my kids I then do
the best I can to make it up in other
places
um on my schedule and again I know I've
got some privilege here but I don't miss
I don't miss kids
um like theater performance I'm not
going to miss a play I'm not going to
miss a choir performance my daughter got
a part as the big rooster in her
upcoming something or other for first
graders I'm not gonna miss that so
that's gonna cost me money to show up to
that and it's worth every single penny
of it I'll also say this last night was
one of the most extraordinary moments of
my life at 3am about 3 15 in the morning
my daughter woke woke me and my wife up
she came in the bedroom woke us up and
said she couldn't sleep and I'm so tired
I got so many deadline I'm just out of
gas but I heard in her voice this deep
frustration
like I just want to be asleep and I
can't and I have I've struggled through
insomnia my whole life and I knew it I
heard it I felt it so I got up I'm gonna
get choked up here hold on I got up and
I went and got an apple
she told me she was hungry I can't sleep
whatever and I used our little apple
slicer and I got a plate and I went and
sat on her bed and we ate apples at 3 15
3 20 in the morning until about four and
we laughed so hard and she told me about
this dumb Boys in her class and oh it
was a really precious time and so
sometimes we think how do I show up in
these moments we gotta go to Disneyland
we got it no dude eat apples with your
kid on her bed at 3 30 in the morning
she'll tell that story at your funeral
so all right Kelly
I keep going over the little Dinger
sorry that's okay all right my wife left
and I'm a single dad of two daughters
what do I do when they start to reach
puberty how do I approach the sensitive
topics with them
I want to desensitize puberty
it's
like if you're a dad and you can't talk
to your daughter about your peer her
period like that's that's on you it's a
it's her body it's a natural thing it's
like not a weird strange oh good shut up
get over yourself have the conversations
if you don't know how to have the
conversations get with
um some
women that you trust and ask hey how
should I have this conversation with my
daughter what's ways that you had it in
your life that you didn't have in your
life that so number one I want to take
away any weird stuff whether it's Sons
or daughters
um my wife will be able to have
particular experiential conversations
that are different than I can have with
my daughter 100 there's going to be a
conversations that they need to go just
have by themselves awesome
but I don't need to be in my house like
oh periods that's just it's part of it
or you're growing up it's time to go get
bras where like that's life and so
making that as weird as possible is not
weird as possible not making your
daughters ever feel like they have
something to apologize about their
bodies or they're somehow broken or
weird that's number one number two get a
couple of adult women in their lives
that they can trust whether that's an
aunt whether that's um a teacher
somebody that they trust even offer to
put some money on the table hey would
you take my daughter to dinner well I'm
trying to build relationships with other
women that I trust because she's going
to need people to call this because
she's not gonna always want to call her
dad with stuff like that
um and so have set up uh curate
relationships with other adults in her
life in their lives that they Trust
all right we're pregnant with our first
and I'm scared it's going to change our
relationship
what can we do to keep things the same
between us I know oh bless bless your
hearts
it's gonna change a hundred percent of
everything all of it will be different
now
every bit of it is different
so you have two Avenues ahead of you you
can know that everything's gonna be
different so we're going on an adventure
together arm in arm and we're going to
reimagine sex and we're going to
reimagine entertainment we're going to
reimagine time and calendars and work
all that stuff
or you can almost guarantee the end of
your relationship by constantly
comparing it to what it used to be and
trying to drag it backwards and make
that happen again
because it won't it won't everything you
knew is over now
the way your husband or wife looks CH uh
uh ax but like all everything's
different now everything's different so
bless your sweet little Souls
um you can't because it's all Gonna
Change it's all Gonna Change
all right we can't get our teenager to
come out of his room
what can we do to encourage him to
participate in family activities like
eating dinner as a family or church on
Sunday oh geez okay
anytime somebody tells me they can't
fill in the blank with their kid I
always throw a flag on that
you can
unhook the computer and throw it in the
freaking garbage you can take the door
off the hinges you can take all of the
desks and chairs out of your kid's room
what you want to do is you want to have
some magic hack or some magic pill so
that you don't look like the bad guy you
don't look like you're intervening but
that your son will magically just follow
a trail of of gummy bears out of his
room into the family
whatever it's not gonna happen you're
gonna have to
get your kid out of his room that's
number one number two often kids don't
like to play games with parents because
parents aren't fun to be around
they're the worst
they're always criticizing and judging
and trying to Bow up and they can't they
can't lose at a board game without
getting their feelings hurt or all mad
but so be somebody that your kid wants
to be around don't be an annoying pain
in the butt adult who always has a
lesson ready to go and always
like be somebody that you'd want to hang
out with
and make some of these things uh I
remember when I was a kid my dad told me
if you don't want to go to the church
where we all go great
faith is important to me and our family
lineage go somewhere go somewhere I'll
drop you off and I didn't realize at the
time what a big deal that was
um but what he was saying was
your faith you having deep roots in this
thing called belief into something
bigger than you are is more important
than making than our little picture of a
pretty family
um on Sunday mornings at some church
then some Olin Mills photo
that's
that's when your kid sees you being
honest and authentic not using him as a
part of a performance
and so if your kids won't come out of
the room you can get them out
it's just gonna depend on how much you
love them
we do the thing so we all go to church
together on Sunday but my son goes to a
different church for uh youth group on
Wednesday night with some friends and he
loves it that's great doesn't matter to
me all right how do you explain death to
young children
I mean that's that's a tough question is
any get
no the the
the way David Kessler explains it that I
love and what I've used repeatedly is
when I'm talking to a kid about a
funeral
I will say something along the lines of
you know how when we celebrate
somebody's birthday
it's a it's our way of saying we love
you and we see you and we're celebrating
you a funeral is the same way it's us
telling them that we love you we always
will love you and we're gonna miss you
and so I try to contextualize that
ceremony
um
I'll just give you the two examples
because it's such a broad-ranging
question with my 13 year old when we
talked about we had the Nashville
shooting here with my 13 year old
um we went out for a walk and I talked a
lot more open with him about what he had
heard about what actually happened about
the Proto safety protocols about how the
SWAT officers responded because I've
done SWAT trainings before and I've had
SWAT officers come get me and um so I
was able to just give him a play by play
and then also I was really clear about
the statistics it's probably not going
to happen it's probably not going to
happen but it does
with my daughter we went and got on the
trampoline and I laid down on my stomach
I got eye level with her so she knew her
body knew this is not a this is not Dad
lecturing this is not dad being scariest
dad being with her and so there's
something really important about body
position and
um uh eye level so that her body
uh regulates itself it gets still and it
gets slow and I asked her did you hear
about what happened and I let her tell
me what she knew
and I confirmed some she knew a lot more
than I thought she did but we're just at
a place now where we can't hide this
stuff from kids anymore so talking about
death is really important and here's the
other important part about talking about
death let your kids see You Weep let
your kids see you be upset let your kids
see you be really really sad
because they have those same feelings
too and they need to see you have those
experiences so they don't feel crazy
they don't learn at a young age to stuff
all their feelings down and try to hide
them because that's what Mom and Dad do
no man let your kids see you cry let
your kids see you be really really
scared
um that's a gift
all right our son plays video games it's
where he connects with friends should we
limit his Play Time Each Day yes
absolutely 100 percent
um
I don't have any good data off the top
of my head I wish I did I don't have any
data on like here's too much and here's
too little
um I can tell you my house I broke down
and got a Nintendo switch for my son for
Christmas I know I did
I did
um and he gets one hour a week on
Saturdays when all the other it's it's
purely a reward thing
um
so that's how I do it
um academics are important in our house
connectivity with our family is really
important in our house and everybody
participating like my son does chores my
daughter does chores me and my wife do
chores and so the
the connectivity in our home is more
important than connectivity with friends
and
um also I don't he's he's not allowed to
do it online so that's a whole different
story there
um have you all drawn boundaries in your
house
changed kind
of
um right now Nathan is allowed to play
until six o'clock because by the time
we're usually not home
um and then that's usually about the
time I'm working on dinner so he has to
come and sit in the the kitchen and
that's where he works on homework and if
he doesn't have homework
then
you just said he just we talk or
whatever yeah um but he's allowed to
play until but he plays usually you know
even because he plays online now because
he plays with
um with other kids you know but I always
walk in who's that who's that who's that
and um and there's been a couple times
where it was like I don't know that
person and that does not sound like a
kid yeah you know
um of course he's 17. now so none of
them sound like kids anymore exactly um
but we know all the people that he's
playing with but um we've just put a
time limit on it and
that's kind of a
non-negotiable yeah I think a broader
conversation that families need to have
is
why is this more appealing than
being connected with us and that's just
a it's just a helpful framing question
so as you get to be 17 there's some
natural I want to be around my friends
right and that's and we had to come to
the understanding of
we were like we'll go outside play with
your friends do this that's not what
they do yeah exactly it's just not no he
drives now so he and his friends would
they'll go to dinner or go hang out but
it's just not where they are now it's
different and so we've we had to kind of
come to that realization that this is
where he hangs out with his friends I've
I've had to not be an idiot is what I
would say yeah well like do you not want
me to have friends I mean that's the
exact conversation I have like like I
don't think you understand dad like I'm
I'm on the outside of every conversation
here and I love that I know how to care
for sick chickens I know that I can work
a lawnmower and a small tractor and I
can
I I know how to
Harvest a deer
but man I just want to sit at lunch and
talk to my friends there's room for all
of it as long as it's in the right place
that's right and the priorities right
yes and I think maybe that's the most
important thing our family like we're
very clear how low on the totem pole of
a priority that is that is pure that is
that is marshmallows and gummy candy
um on the back end of a healthy meal
or as a way to cope yeah really that's
where you're going with it I last night
again listen last night in ah
I was walking through so I was feeding
the dogs and I saw a bag of miniature
marshmallows and I just took a handful
I'm hanging on man hanging on all right
next question we're gonna get there all
right next question let's do it as our
kids get older I've noticed our
parenting styles are different it causes
tensions between us and confusion for
the kids what do we do
talk about it
talk about it talk about it talk about
it and when you talk about this don't go
with again off-site
get out of your house go somewhere plan
to spend a few hours
spend the money even if you don't have
it spend the money and
don't sit down and say hey you're
letting those kids run all over that's
not what we're gonna do because then
your spouse has to fight you because you
just you just punched first
I know we both want to make amazing
adults and I don't like how I'm showing
up right now for the kids and I'm
hearing them be really disrespectful to
me and I'm seeing them be disrespectful
to other people
we got to come together on our parenting
stuff and I'm gonna put my stuff on the
table first I'm struggling what are you
struggling with or are you struggling
with anything and hopefully there's some
your your spouse has some ability to be
reflective it's like yeah I don't know
what to do here I'm struggling with this
but let's reimagine this thing together
if you get into an accusation War then
your parents parents are going to pick
sides kids can smell that a mile away
they're gonna pick sides and it's just
gonna be this divided house don't do
that
how do you balance 30-second hugs and
asking your daughter's permission to
touch her
um I default to her saying no so her
autonomy over her body trumps my
um
uh
my understanding of the importance of
skin to skin contact I will say this I
think I talked about this on the show
but my wife called out several months
ago
um
this idea of if you weren't so hard to
be around if you weren't so electric all
the time if you weren't always lecturing
all the time and saying like why are you
wearing the shoes why you got that shirt
on why are you doing
if you would be fun to be around
um that would change
and I tell you what I've worked really
hard on that and it has been
transformative in my house
and so it again using what happened last
night I could have said go to bed it's
three o'clock in the morning
uh we'll do it in the morning
I just got up and for those of you
wondering yes I ended up missing my
workout I skipped my workout I barely
made it to work and um I'll be chasing
deadlines all day
I spent an hour on my daughter's bed not
even an hour 40 minutes eating apples
chilling listening to her she told me
stories
um
man the hugs on the back end of that
will come the hugs on that will come but
I'm always going to default too she is
chiefly in charge of her body
all right last question by the way that
also is for uncles grandparents
everybody everybody
why don't you go hug Granddad no she
says no Then she says no what's another
what's another way you could tell
Granddad that you're glad that he came
what's another way you could tell Uncle
whoever because her body is saying that
guy's not safe and I don't want to hug
him cool all right go go for it all
right last question my daughter does
competitive gymnastics she wants to quit
but I think she should keep at it
because she's talented and she could get
a scholarship
do I make her keep competing
who
I'm gonna speak my concerns out loud
okay
on its face no
you should not continue to make your
kids keep competing at a highly
competitive level with this imaginary
idea that um your kid's gonna get a
scholarship especially and you've got to
be really honest with yourself and most
parents can't do this
especially
um we used to call we used to call it
the soccer mom scholarship and when I
was working in higher ed here's why
I could give a student a ten thousand
dollar
um my college could give no scholarships
and I'll make up a number here a fake
number because clearly this isn't true
and our total tuition was ten thousand
dollars for the year
College down the street their tuition
was twenty thousand dollars but they
would give your kid
um a one thousand dollar JV soccer
scholarship
so the total out of pocket is 19 Grand
on this school 10 grand on this school
95 times out of 100 we lost that student
to the more expensive school so that
parents could go around and tell
everybody that their kid was on a soccer
scholarship
it's all part of the enrollment game
and so if you want to be the parent of a
scholarship athlete you need to check
yourself because you're about to lose
your kid
I will also say
as a youngster I tried to quit several
times
I was uh
big Tech big super 5A Texas high school
football player and I went to track I
went to college on track scholarship I
tried to quit both and my parents said
no
but they let my brother quit and I
remember challenging them on that as I
was older and they said y'all are very
different people
you needed the structure you needed
other adults because you weren't
listening to us to push you harder than
you thought you need to be pushed and it
wasn't for scholarships it was if it was
my parents saw a developmental need that
I needed that they couldn't provide and
so they wouldn't let me my brother on
the other hand
was it was amazing like he was a
structured human being he still is he's
amazing we're very different people and
so they were able to look at him and say
he's not going to need the same
structure here and here's the catch the
the kicker
um I let my kid quit one sport but he
had to choose something else to do he
can't just sit home and do nothing so
cool you do not have to do competitive
this anymore what is the sport and what
is the instrument you're gonna you're
gonna choose and so if they are like Oh
I thought I could just do nothing and
hang out with my friends that's not
gonna happen you gotta do something
it doesn't have to be competitive this
or that or this or that and mom and dads
you can always
what I saw on Instagram the other day it
was uh every dad thinks if I just worked
a little bit harder as high schooler I
could have made the NFL no you couldn't
no you couldn't you know how I know you
could so don't put that on your kids if
you just worked a little harder you can
go pro they're not going pro they're not
going pro
um so give them some peace there
is that good that was great cool nice
work